what are the various types of asset
management systems how is this
technology evolving how can they help
operationalize a strategy for building
optimized and sustainable business
operations these are a few of the
questions I'll answer here I'm Eric Le
bone the CTO for Asset Management
Solutions and IBM sustainability
software
so let's start at the beginning
at its most basic form an asset
management system allows companies to
manage data about their physical assets
so they can monitor measure and maintain
the equipment they need to operate their
businesses
these systems appeared over 50 years ago
so companies can manage schedules and
tasks for large maintenance projects in
utilities manufacturing and
transportation Industries
these early systems focus on time-based
scheduling some asset information and
basic task management
they also supported field operations
with location and maintenance
information ultimately leading to the
adoption of mobile devices to do
repeatable basic maintenance and
installation they were considered
maintenance project management
applications
but very quickly these maintenance
Management Systems exploded with
expanded data requirements tied to a
broader set of needs for example from
operational processes repair
instructions warranties safety processes
professional licenses and skills
financials and so on
the result
the fully functional Enterprise asset
management system or eam was born it
includes integrated data models and
prescriptive workflows plus Integrations
with corporate Erp systems eam is now
this industry standard for asset
intensive Enterprises who need to
maintain Best in Class return on those
assets for example IBM maximum customers
have been able to reduce asset downtime
over 43 percent
an increased maintenance productivity 44
percent
But ultimately companies needed to move
Beyond preventive and reactive
maintenance especially with asset
downtime being so disruptive so
companies began instrumenting assets
with software sensors and cameras to
analyze the rich operating data in real
time and Leverage The Cloud to manage
the volumes of data being collected
real-time data enables condition-based
monitoring and Predictive Analytics to
further reduce risk increase asset
uptime and cut unnecessary labor costs
and even track energy usage of assets
it's now possible to apply Advanced
statistical and analytical models and
leverage AI Technologies to more deeply
understand asset performance
this approach called asset Performance
Management or APM extends eam
capabilities with asset Health
predictive maintenance remote asset
monitoring and computer vision using
anomaly detection Visual and audio data
analysis Etc so assets are analyzed 24 7
to identify issues before they can
negatively impact the business now
environmentally conscious companies are
seeing research that shows that assets
Drive 76 percent of greenhouse gas
emissions and believe that they need to
play a bigger role in reducing their
impact on our environment
they're looking to understand how
greenhouse gases are created through the
operation of assets then they'll be able
to identify where excess emissions are
occurring and can drive sustainability
initiatives to reduce the impact of
their operations on the environment
this approach is called sustainable
Asset Management it uses carbon
management modeling to monitor waste and
Emissions connecting Asset Management
analytics and workflows focused on
increasing the life of their operating
assets reducing energy consumption and
minimizing the fossil fuel use with best
practice prescriptive guidance
Asset Management Systems have
continually served as a foundation for
solving big data issues for industrial
companies and clients are finding that
sustainability challenge is no different
getting a handle on the data is a
critical First Step help you understand
how where and by how much to transform
operations to balance net income would
Net Zero goals I appreciate you joining
me and hope you take time to learn more
about how sustainable Asset Management
can help your organization create more
positive outcomes for the world around
us thank you